Reconstruction is that period of American history that I think still,
I know still is short shrifted in the ways people tend to learn American history
in this society for whatever the reason.
Part of the reason may be that it's messy and complicated and part of the reason
may be that it's full of violence and part of the reason may be that it's just
not as easy to find good heroes.
And part of the reason may be that it comes after such a total all out and some
may say in so many ways,
glorious war or as Kenneth stamp a greatest story in once put it until 1865
there was Gloria enough to go around,
but after 1865 where it was the glory,
it's also been a period in which we've almost insisted,
and I wonder just how you have learned about this before,
if this were a smaller class,
I would ask you,
but it's,
it's as though our culture still insist from this period of our history that
it'd be a mellow drama,
some kind of melodrama with a sufficient number of heroes in a sufficient number
of villains.
And a melodrama that usually ends up with a story of an oppressed south
much in need of our sympathy.
Okay.
No,
I've,
I've put a piece of words up here in front of you.
I walked back to see if he could read it.
I do think most of you in the room can read it and just hold onto the papers
until the end please.
Um,
this is the 13th amendment.
We're going to look at the 13th and the 14th today,
or at least I'll get you up to the 14th amendment.
If the civil war and reconstruction where a second founding,
I'll put the ephod on that.
Although for the next three weeks,
I'm going to argue that if it was a second founding,
a second revolution of some kind.
Okay,
that's second founding is in the 13th the 14th the 15th amendments to the
Constitution.
Read the 13th with me.
It's the simplest shortest other than the actual parts of the bill of rights,
it's the simplest shortest amendment in the u s constitution.
It outlaws slavery and involuntary servitude except for imprisonment,
for crime.
And then it has that very,
very simple section too.
Congress shall have power to enforce this article by appropriate legislation
that is almost
in some ways,
um,
a precis for what reconstruction will become,
what will constitute appropriate reconstruction.
I excuse me,
legislation.
What will constitute appropriate legislation to enforce black freedom?
I put it up today in part two because just this weekend I was out of lecturing
in Springfield,
Illinois at the new Abraham Lincoln Presidential Library
and it's a magnificent place if you haven't been there.
Uh,
it's a museum full of lots of wax figures that Liz is at least one life size wax
of Lincoln and every bloody room,
sometimes two of them.
And then they use holograms and he appears all over the place.
It's a little weird and scary,
but at the end of the whole day,
in the evening,
they took me down on the vault and asked me if I wanted to see some special
documents and special possessions
and showed me one of Lincoln's three existing top hats.
They showed me the cast of his hand.
I got to touch,
they showed me personal notes.
He wrote to pardon,
um,
deserters from the union army.
They showed me all kinds of things,
but one of the things they showed me was the original draft,
the hand written draft by the clerk of the House of Representatives of the 13th
amendment and then signed by a Lincoln and most of the members of the house,
at least those who chose to sign it.
And I realized,
damn,
that thing is real
and maybe someday I can live to see the 14th amendment
back to the 14th animal.
MMM,
sorry about that.
That's not the 14th.
That's just the outline
now.
Um,
a few overall thoughts on reconstruction to just give you some hooks to hang
your hat on before we look back again at this question of reconstruction during
the war and then after Lincoln's death,
the fight that ensues quickly between the new president,
Andrew Johnson and the congressional leadership,
the Republican Party soon now to be known as the radical Republicans and what
would be,
will become a great constitutional crisis over who will control reconstruction
and what reconstruction will be reconstruction.
No is often seen it indeed and your of um,
almost gargantuan aspirations if you think about what they were trying to
achieve and tragic failures
it,
but it's also an air of sudden and unprecedented legal,
political and constitutional change.
It's also a period of tremendous social and political violence.
And we've never experienced anything in America other than sanction war,
which the civil war of course it's been,
we've never ever experienced social and political violence on the scale that
you'll see in reconstruction.
In fact,
there's a whole batch of books coming out now on reconstruction violence.
And I suspect this has a lot to do with living in the age of terrorism.
Publishers are really promoting the subject you're reading one of them that's
just been out a year or two by Nicholas Lemann called redemption or not.
And a week or two
and another way reconstruction was one long,
10 11 year agonizing referendum on the meaning of the war.
One of the war meant that's what reconstruction was trying to explain,
trying to saddle,
trying to codify
what had actually been the verdict at Appomattox when Lee surrendered and then
Johnson surrendered.
And then in the confederate army surrendered.
What was the verdict?
Who got to determine it?
Who would really won the war
and what have they won?
What cause had lost?
Now someone really won this war and someone really lost this war.
This is not one of those wars.
Where are you going to say,
you know,
nobody ever wins a war?
Nonsense
Union victory is real.
Confederate defeat was virtually total
in a military sense,
but what was the south to lose?
One of the greatest challenges of reconstruction was to determine how you take
this massive national blood feud of unimaginable scale.
You know it's beginning
and then reconcile it into a new nation.
The problem in part is that the survivors on both sides in this war would still
have to inhabit the same land in the same country.
It wasn't as though an actual foreign country had been conquered and defeated it
part of North America.
It was part of the u s or as soon to be new US s of some kind
and the side the last is going to have to in time and habit,
the same government.
How,
where do you go and precedent?
Where do you go in history?
Where do you go in the constitution?
Where do you look this up to put Humpty dumpty back together again.
Put another way.
The task was how to make the eventual logic of sectional reconciliation knitting
north and South back together.
How to make the eventual logic of sectional reconciliation somehow compatible
with the logic of that revolution that was put in place in 1863
or in other words,
emancipation and by logic I mean you have to put north and south back together,
but you also now have to deal with the fact the slaves had been free to some new
status.
Got To do both.
Put another way.
How do you square black freedom and all the stirrings of the possibility at
least of racial equality.
Now with that,
because in the south that had lost everything except it's faith in white
supremacy.
Okay,
how do you fold black freedom into white supremacy?
How do you wore white Ho for white supremacy in the black freedom?
Can they ever be?
Could those ever be reconciled and what if they can't?
Lincoln spoke of a testing and the Gettysburg address.
If you remember the famous speech testing,
whether that nation or any nation so conceived can long endure
the testing of the war
in some ways would become easier than the testing the country would know face
with reconstruction or finally put yet another way,
and I wrote about this
too much length and book called race and Reunion.
The challenge of reconstruction,
and it's the challenge we've had ever since,
is how do you do two profound things at the same time?
One was healing
and the other was justice.
How do you have them both?
What truly constitutes healing of a people of a nation that's suffered this
scale of violence and destruction
and how do you have justice and justice for whom?
Here's what Lincoln said next to the last day of his life,
three days before he was shot,
it was his last public utterance from a balcony at the White House.
He was discussing reconstruction is audience that day one and to just hear about
the glories of the ending of the war and he gave him a little mini lecture on
reconstruction because that's precisely what he was dealing with.
He said,
this
reconstruction is pressed much more close to the upon our attention.
Now it is fraught with great difficulty.
Unlike the case of a war between independent nations,
there is no authorized Oregon for us to treat with no one may and has authority
to give up the rebellion for any other man.
We simply must begin with and mold from disorganized in discordant elements with
all so new and unprecedented is the whole case that no exclusive and in flexible
plan can safely be prescribed as to detail,
but important principles must be in flexible.
That's classic Lincoln.
No one plan must we necessarily commit to,
but we must stick to some principles.
It's linked in the pragmatist trying to figure it out and then he's dead.
The back to war time at least for a few minutes.
The debate over reconstruction as it will play out through the next three years,
four years,
really five years up to 1870 71 is the debate that ensued between Lincoln and
his own party leadership and congress as early as late 1863 here's the Lincolns
plan again and you can read.
You can read all of this and phone is short history of reconstruction,
but let me give it to you at least in brief terms.
You'll remember I said the other day that Lincoln wanted reconstruction to be
presidential lenient and quick.
He was openly friendly to southerners.
His whole life is,
I suppose everybody knows for brother-in-law's and fought for the confederacy
and Cetera,
et cetera.
He's born in Kentucky.
He did not really have any kind of personal vindictiveness toward southerners
the way many others on the Republican Party will have and they'll have reasons
to have that.
Some have argued is kind of stamp.
Once that Lincoln actually had a deep personal need for personal app solution,
that he carried this horrifying burden of all that death and that he did.
He took it as his personal responsibility and that this charity for all and
malice toward none and the leniency in Lincoln's a reconstruction ideas is
somehow rooted and that sense of personal responsibility for all of the
suffering.
Maybe something to that.
Okay,
but he's reconstruction policies such as he put it in place,
at least for awhile,
was rooted in his constitutional philosophy.
Lincoln number one beliefs.
The session had never happened.
That's the session was essentially impossible.
A state could not secede from the union.
He chose language carefully as a good lawyer.
He said as states,
the southern states,
the confederate states,
we're still in the union.
Technically during the war,
even though they succeeded,
they were simply in his language,
out of their normal relationship to the union,
wherever the hell that supposed to mean
on the fourth is total war against the United States,
but they were not really out of the union.
Now that's a legal position.
Rest assured,
he made a distinction between states and governments.
He said their governments may have,
you know,
uh,
failed and committed.
He never used the word treason,
you know,
made rebellion against the United States.
But as states in Alabama,
never cease to exist.
Okay?
He's famous for saying things like physically we cannot separate.
His idea was to squash the rebellion.
Let a number of loyal citizens in one of those seceded states create a new loyal
government,
restore that state to the Union as quickly as possible,
even before the war ends by presidential authority under presidential war powers
and begin a process before you'd ever have a surrender of what he was already
calling restoration or reunification.
Okay.
He wanted it done by executive authority.
That wasn't necessarily a personal power grab by any means,
but he wanted to do it under presidential war powers because he did understand,
to the extent anybody could predict the future.
And once the war did in Congress's powers would rise.
A president has never so powerful as in time of war.
Yeah.
Pause for a moment.
What they're all thinking about now.
Lincoln,
the Republican leadership of Congress.
Anybody thinking about reconstruction during the war or even in immediate
aftermath is really thinking about a set of questions that are somewhat like
those big questions I started with,
but more specifically,
this is what they have to think about now.
And if you think American statesman have been challenged at other times in our
history,
how would you like to have this Jones?
One,
three,
three main questions.
One,
who would rule in the south
who,
who gets to vote because the whole office x,
confederates,
black people,
whites had been loyal.
How do you determine this
to who will rule in the federal government,
Congress or the president in this unprecedented blank slate set of issues?
Country had never faced this before.
How do you reconstruct a union?
How do you readmit states into the union?
There's no blueprint and the constitution,
there are hints depending on how you interpret it.
And three,
what will the dimensions of black freedom be in law and in practice and in
social life on the ground in south.
All the while remembering that this all must occur now in these desperate
conditions of poverty,
destruction,
starvation,
and tremendous untold as yet not even fully fathom.
Bitterness and hatred
are,
let me give you one last little question.
I love asking questions.
I don't have to stand up right now and answer
would reconstruction via preservation of something old
or the creation of something truly new
and if it's going to be new,
how new.
Back to the war warriors
Lincoln issued on December eight,
1863,
the,
his,
uh,
state of the union or annual message,
part of his annual message,
what he called the proclamation of amnesty and reconstruction.
It was issued December 63 dimensional thinking.
Remember the dates here because all this first major debate on reconstruction is
going to occur and some of the most terrible months of the war and yet in
Washington,
and they're also having this debate.
There were several parts to this,
but three main ones.
It's clay as Lincoln's classic,
lenient,
rapid,
moderate,
and presidential reconstruction.
It's called the 10% plan.
He,
number one would pardon all x confederates with a certain list of exceptions,
high ranking confederate officials.
Although he didn't entirely clarify how high ranking,
they wouldn't be pardoned.
He at least yet,
he would not pardon those who had resigned commissions in the judiciary or in
Congress to support the confederacy.
Yeah.
And he put in a clause that said he would not pardon those who could be
convicted of mistreating black soldiers,
of which there have been a great deal of,
and he was under some pressure to do something about that by late 63
and then he said when 10% of the voting population of a given southern state and
the voting population was determined by how many voted in 1860 when 10% of the
male voting population,
cause that's the only people who could vote,
would take an oath to the union
and establish a new government than he is president under presidential war
powers would recognize them and readmit them to the union
just like that.
Blacks were excluded from the entire process.
There was a,
there was no mention at that point of any black suffrage.
He wants 10%
now right away,
members of his own party in Congress are saying,
wait a second,
Mr President,
what about the other 90%
well,
Lincoln's idea was if you can establish a pocket of people in Lower Louisiana or
upland Alabama or part of Virginia that the union troops occupied and you get,
if you can get 10% of that state there,
take a loyalty oath and Alexa,
I'm kind of a little rump legislature that can meet somewhere like wheeling West
Virginia,
where they did for awhile.
Then he would call that the Real Virginia or the real Louisiana and they'd be
back in the union and he,
his idea was that you would begin that a political process of reunification,
a political process would already be in place,
as messy as it might be,
as seemingly undemocratic as it might be before the war would end.
This actually happened.
Well,
he didn't,
they didn't get admitted to the union,
but so called Lincoln governments were established in three states.
Again,
we're union armies had significant occupation of the soil of that state.
Louisiana,
Tennessee,
and Arkansas and so called Lincoln.
Governments were created there in 1864 and early 1865 they were pitifully weak
governments.
They would have collapsed entirely without federal troops to protect them.
And Lincoln did this utterly without consulting with Congress and we like to
make a great deal of Abraham Lincoln is the greatest president and he was
political genius and he was magical with the music of words and he was,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And I was just out at the Lincoln Library where you can be sure Lincoln has god,
but not consulting with Congress on this one.
Wasn't the wisest thing he ever did.
Yeah.
Congress began to react with great hostility in 1864
some radical republicans sincerely believed that these new Lincoln governments
were not only wrong and undemocratic,
the dangerous,
and they wanted much,
much more to even consider the reconstruction of a southern state on any basis
they were led.
They being the
Republicans in Congress
by the two men on your right.
Oh,
oops,
sorry.
Thaddeus Stevens on the top and Charles Sumner on the bottom.
Steven's a congressman from Pennsylvania who grew up and live near Gettysburg.
Fascinating,
interesting,
driven,
passionate,
complicated club footed man.
Okay,
brilliant lawyer
and a radical and then old abolitionists.
And although he had some complications along the way,
Stephen's in some nurse Sumner,
the great senator from Massachusetts to Sumner,
who had had the brains nearly beaten out of them by Preston Brooks in the
congress in 1856 and Senate in 1856 and left the Senate for nearly three and a
half years.
And when all over the world to spas to try to put his,
his head back together and coding,
spending most of a year in Switzerland was very,
very much back in the game during the war.
And he rose in power of course,
as the emancipation issue rose to the fore as did Stevens.
And the two of them led the response,
the Lincolns ideas on reconstruction from the two different houses of Congress.
They had different names for their proposals,
but they're essentially argued the same thing.
Although Sumner's that you could argue was even more radical.
Stevens called his approach or his constitutional approach,
conquered provinces.
He said,
not only do the southern states secede from the union,
they should be reverted to the status Ivonne organized,
territory's,
or even further,
he went.
He said,
no,
they're not only going to have to be put under territorial status,
but they should be treated like a foreign nation that the United States has
conquered a conquered province of a foreign land.
They had been reduced by force of arms.
They had made war upon the United States and under international law.
Steven's argued they should be treated as quote,
his words,
conquered foreign land,
subject to whatever the United States shall choose to do with it.
Sumner for his part called this theory,
it was even more direct state suicide.
I was pretty clear.
He said,
not only of the southern states secede from the union,
they committed political suicide.
They do not exist.
They experienced what he called,
in his words,
instant forfeiture of their status as states.
They therefore must be reverted to what he called the status of on organized.
Territory's as though Alabama was back in 1820
Virginia was back in 1787 or you know,
whatever year they became officially became a state.
I'm sorry,
before that,
even during the revolution.
And therefore in both cases,
Stevens or Sumner's plan all authority to readmit any southern state or
determine the process.
The means by which the laws by which a state would be re instituted into the
union came under Congressional Authority because only Congress has the power to
readmit new states.
Take that Abraham Lincoln,
they issued this theory to Lincoln in what was known as the Wade Davis Bill in
July 4th of July to be exact 1864 note the date this is,
this is in the midst of the stalemate
in Virginia.
It's just after coal harbor.
Uh,
grant has just begun to put Petersburg under siege.
The terrible blood letting in Virginia is coming in the thousands and thousands
of names and casualty list and congress issues.
No.
It's known as the Wade Davis bill named for Senator Benjamin Weight of Ohio,
a strong slavery radical Republican and Henry Henry Winter Davis of congressman
from Maryland also have at least moderate antislavery cadet credentials.
What you have here is the blueprint of radical reconstruction,
at least the beginning blueprint,
the way Davis Bill said they took,
the first part of it was they took Lincoln's 10% idea,
10% of the voting population of southern state,
and they required a majority of white male citizens of a southern state
who must secondly take what the radicals called an iron clad oath,
and that all said that they had no,
they had to get up and swear they had never participated in the confederate war
effort or aided and abetted it.
Now immediately you're wondering,
how in hell are you going to find them white?
A majority of the white males of Georgia or Alabama or Mississippi or any other
confederate state,
they can get up and take that oath.
The answer is you couldn't.
To the congressional leadership,
that was just fine.
For now,
the iron clad oath was a political message.
It was a symbolic coasts.
They knew you'd never get a majority of whites who could take this third part.
They said all officer's above the rank of lieutenant and all civil officers of
all kinds in the confederacy would not only be not pardoned,
they would be disfranchised forever declared,
not the actual language in the bill was not a citizen of the United States.
It was almost as though they were giving every office holder,
every officer lieutenant above who was still alive in the south and invitation
to leave the country because if they stayed in America,
they would be men without a country.
They did not set up in spite of the Lord.
That said in over the years a plan of arrest indictments and executions.
They didn't do that at all.
Okay,
but they did decide they were going to treat.
The southern states has conquered enemies.
They sent the bill to Lincoln
and Lincoln did.
What many presidents have done.
He gave it a pocket veto.
You know what that is.
He simply let the bill die without either signing it or vetoing it,
or to some extent even answering it.
Although he did finally answer it,
answered it.
Actually four days after the bill was delivered to him and what he titled The
proclamation on the way Davisville,
and this was,
this was a classic Lincoln ESC statement as well.
It was conciliatory.
He thanked them profusely for their work on the sensitive and terrible issue,
and he didn't completely reject it.
He refused.
He said to be,
quote,
inflexibly committed to anyone.
Plan.
Okay,
but what are you committed to?
Is what Congress began to say.
He was verbally willing to listen,
but he really did not play Kate the radicals.
They had an impasse here,
big impasse,
and known how deep the impasse is,
its constitutional.
Who's gonna run reconstruction?
Me The president or you the congress.
Well,
the congressional leadership followed Lincoln's little,
a proclamation on the Wade Davis bill with what they called the way Davis
Manifesto,
and they published it in national newspapers.
It was published in August 5th,
1864 it was an unprecedented vehement attack on a sitting president by the
leadership in Congress of his own party.
They lamb basted Lincoln.
They attacked him on two grounds.
They said his approach to reconstruction was simply way too lenient,
and they're arguing this now in August of 1864 with these thousands upon
thousands of casualties flowing in.
This is a very time Lincoln comes to believe he's not a bug,
not likely to be reelected,
and there was some members in particularly the radical wing of the Republican
Party who had been laboring to dump Lincoln from the ticket all summer and
probably could have succeeded in doing it if there wasn't so much at stake
and they want a second step.
They actually accused him of usurpation of presidential powers,
an impeachable offense if anyone ever cared to take it any further step.
Here's the key.
As the dispute emerge that summer,
Lincoln viewed reconstruction as a means to weakening the confederacy and
winning the war.
Think of it as a political strategy.
That 10% idea,
trying to get some fledgling little state legislature and government somehow get
two or three of them into the union.
It was a strategy.
None,
no,
not a blueprint.
A written in stone for the way we construct and would always be,
but to the radical Republicans,
they viewed this as a much more far reaching trans formation and a building
really of a new nation when and if they can win the war.
They really were at an impasse.
Now,
you know from our previous lectures and you're reading that that the fall of
mobile bay on August 5th the same day as a,
as a way,
Dave,
his manifesto,
admiral Farragut took mobile bay.
That had a tremendous impact on public opinion.
Then on September three or four the Lana fell and I didn't even greater impact
on public opinion and of course you got the presidential race now happening in
the fall and Lincoln is reelected,
this impasse on reconstruction.
They'll basically just sat there
until Lincoln's death.
In the meantime,
he cooperated and so did they on two tremendous pieces of legislation,
uh,
to great enactments.
One is the 13th amendment,
which we just discussed.
And I want to come back to that in a moment.
Um,
well actually I'll mention it now.
The fact that it got passed is fairly remarkable that it got passed.
It all is fairly remarkable.
It is
first of all,
an amendment that Lincoln himself by late 64 began to advocate,
especially after his reelection vehemently advocate.
And it's something exactly what the radical Republicans won it.
They were absolutely on the same page on this.
And the reason Lincoln was,
well,
he had moral reasons to believe slayer.
You should now be eradicated in the constitution.
Um,
make no mistake.
But he also had reason to want this in a constitutional amendment because he
feared,
and rightly so,
that if the war ended with only the emancipation proclamation as the legal
sanction for all those freed slaves,
that there would be nothing to stop southerners from thousands upon thousands of
lawsuits in federal courts suing under Fifth Amendment for their property.
And it would have,
ha it did happen to some extent anyway,
but if you can get it in the constitution as a constitutional amendment,
then they would have no right to sue for property that is no longer property.
So a lot was at stake.
They wanted a 13th amendment because of the potential invalidity of the
emancipation proclamation.
Legally,
they wanted to remove legal doubt and you'll remember that the proclamation only
freed slaves in the states and rebellion.
Technically slaves and Kentucky,
Missouri,
Delaware,
Maryland.
We're still in a kind of limbo.
It passed the House of Representatives on January 31st,
1865 but it was not easy.
You might think you live in the United States of America and of course there'd
be a 13th amendment.
Finally,
of course,
we would outlaw slavery in the constitution.
The vote was one 19 to 56 it passed by two votes,
takes two thirds,
majority for constitutional amendment.
It passed by two votes.
Lincoln began to twist arms and being in a personal meetings with a select
little list of Democrats.
They didn't have a two thirds majority of Republican.
They needed some Democrats to vote for this and by far the majority of Democrats
with nothing to do with our long slavery in the constitution,
but about eight of them came over
and on the day that it was passed,
there was unprecedented rejoicing in the House of Representatives.
The whole hall was full.
Congressmen were told,
started yelling,
crying,
hugging each other,
dancing on the tops of their desks.
God knows why in part because of the importance and the gravity of the issue.
In part perhaps because they've lived through so much agony in the war,
they truly had something to celebrate.
Yeah,
you have to go to individual diaries and letters to really see it.
There was a republican who recorded in his diary that day,
quote,
memories,
excuse me,
members joined in the shouting and kept it up for some minutes.
Some embraced one another.
Others,
a wet black children.
I have felt ever since the vote as though I live in a new country.
Frederick Douglass,
his son,
Louis veteran to the 54th Massachusetts in his uniform was sitting in the
balcony on the afternoon of the 13th amendment was passed.
His father was back home in Rochester.
He immediately wrote his father and note that I've read and said,
father,
you should've been here today.
Today was your day.
And then at the same time that Congress with Lincoln's strong approval worked on
a bill to create the Freedmen's bureau
and unprecedented agency in American history.
Certainly to that time,
formerly called the Bureau of Refugees freedmen and abandoned lands.
It passed Congress on the 3rd of March,
1865 just a day before Lincoln's second inaugural.
It was social reform by military force.
Americans had never done this before.
A national federal social welfare agency.
Okay.
In a land that had lived in breathe,
laissez faire government,
it'll land that have lived and breathed this idea that governments don't provide
food for people.
People provide food for people,
health care schools.
Well,
the war of course,
it forced a new kind of history.
The basic purposes of the Freedmen's bureau when it was set up was to aid
refugees and displaced people,
black or white,
and the estimate,
I may have used this before,
the estimate on the ground in the south by late winter 1865 was that there were
at least a quarter million,
totally displaced,
starving white people,
much less the 4 million soon to be liberated slaves.
Premus bird was proposed to provide all kinds of physical supplies,
medical services,
schools where it could,
it's purpose was also legal to supervise contracts between freedmen and
employees.
More on that later
and it's job and this was an impossible task,
but it's job in its title was to manage confiscated and abandoned land.
Yeah,
property,
but who really owns it now if the union army took your plantation,
who owns that?
No,
and there is nothing more primal,
of course,
especially to Americans and property
now more on the Freedmen's bureau later.
But it was,
it was a terribly important piece of legislation.
It passed with majorities in both houses of course,
because the Republicans had those majorities in Lincoln gladly signed it and it
established at least an agency to be put in place once the war was over.
No.
Let me take the last few minutes
and
set up what is now to happen between old Johnson
and this same leadership of the radical Republicans ones.
Lincoln was gone.
Okay.
This is the classic struggle of Reconstruction Johnson and the radicals.
Now,
first of all,
how did Andrew Johnson get on Lincoln's ticket?
Why did Abraham Lincoln choose Andrew Johnson as his running mate?
I've often put this two major Lincoln scholars,
look,
I confess,
I'm a great admirer of Lincoln's like most people,
but he couldn't do everything perfectly and he gave us Andrew Johnson
and we've never held him responsible for that
and I'm not willing to give them a total pass on that one because Andrew Johnson
ranks down there just about minus two on the list of presidents I think of all
time.
Well,
how's that for directness?
Sorry about that.
If you're an Andrew Johnson fan,
you're lonely.
He's on the ticket and 64 because you know this,
he's the only senator from a succeeded confederate state who didn't succeed with
the state state.
He stayed in the Union from Tennessee.
He's a complicated guy.
God,
he could have been.
Interesting.
Okay.
He had some big flaws.
I'm going to leave you with a little background on Andrew Johnson.
As you can tell from the syllabus,
I've put myself nearly a full lecture behind in the course,
but don't you worry because we're planning for reading week a special review
session one.
I can give another lecture.
Aren't you happy?
There's an old saying about Andrew Johnson that quote old and he never went back
on,
is raising his,
raising up.
He's from East Tennessee.
I was born in North Carolina.
He grew up illiterate,
had once owned 11 slaves.
Although he did freedom.
He moved to East Tennessee with his wife Paula,
who taught him his literacy.
He grew up a Jacksonian Democrat.
His God was Andrew Jackson.
If lovers of the new deal belief FDR was somehow the son of God is my
grandparents.
Did
Andrew Johnson thought Andrew Andrew Johnson throat.
Andrew Jackson was the son of God
in 1861 he was the only southern senator who did not succeed with his state.
In 1862 Lincoln appointed him the war governor of Tennessee,
uh,
in the occupied parts of Tennessee out of woods,
Lincoln.
Eventually it was going to,
he did try to create a new government.
Andrew Johnson was his governor.
It took tremendous courage to be a unionist in Tennessee during the civil war,
but there was a lot of unionism in east Tennessee
and in 64 Lincoln needed a border state running me after a,
who had been his running mate before.
Totally forgettable.
I realize no one ever remembers the vice presidents.
It's from the 19 what's the same?
But I remember Vice Presidents from the 20th century only.
Those would be good getting Nobel prizes to do.
We really remember,
I guess,
but Hannibal Hamlin of New Hampshire had been Lincoln's running me.
Now what good is the New Hampshire right on the ticket and 64 I New Hampshire.
I was useful in 60 but not in 64 so he dumps Hannibal Hamlin,
Sparta,
the alliteration of his name
and goes for a political choice.
What could I,
what can send a better unionists message to the border states than Andrew
Johnson?
Only southern senator doesn't see it from his seat.
Well,
all was pretty well at least until the inauguration.
Andrew Johnson unfortunately was drunk at his inauguration as vice president of
the United States.
Now,
his explanation for that is that he had a terrible tooth infection and he'd been
sloshing down whiskey all morning,
but they literally had to stand him up,
prop him up,
and point them in the right direction and raise it practically raised his hand
on the day he was inaugurated when Lincoln delivered the second inaugural,
a Jay had to be removed to a back room.
Not An auspicious beginning
last thought,
but the fire by far.
The most important thing about Andrew Johnson though,
in spite of his early comments when he said treason must be made odious,
and Charles Sumner said,
Ooh,
he's speaking my language.
The thing we must know about Andrew Johnson is number one,
he was a very little white supremacist.
He was an art and states rightest.
Yes,
he was a state's right as and the unionist.
It's entirely possible to be that he also hated the southern planter class.
He was never anti slavery.
He was not only not antislavery,
he was an open racist.
He believed the United States should remain,
in his own words,
a white man's country for forever,
and he had a disposition that could best charitably be described as
hypersensitive and obstinate.
He was not a flexible politician.
Well,
I'll leave you with old Andrew Johnson now into the story and messing things up
and I'll see you Thursday.